jeonhwa à New York
voici depósito de campaña de côte de un
enseignant novice démocrate voir
économie d'initiative - avocats estimable
groupe Yasuo d'un t-shirt assez végétal à
Macao réfugié faire Michael Bloomberg New
York chaque torsion du torse
Sid nous voyons je pense que l'Amérique va bien
trop loin aux extrêmes des deux côtés
et j'aime le fait qu'il est très
au milieu nous avons besoin de quelqu'un avec
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de nuages beaucoup de gesti
n est la capacité d'obtenir à la Maiso
Blanche un dîner charlatan Carolyn comme
Bloomberg raffiné a supervisé kamijo d'
autres langues, donc Monsanto no Boucher
Paula a créé Aleta Hawaii voir une table a
fait quelque chose qui a été une latina virtuelle
Je pense que la Caroline du Nord est allée amener le
président Barack Obama puis elle est revenue
à Donald Trump et donc ce n'est pas Blues
nitrate est violet et  donc cela signifie
qu'il y a beaucoup d'importance beaucoup de
ressources beaucoup de tension est sur l'
état de Caroline du Nord Mike sur
Bloomberg miss Donna calendrier no nada
que todos ellos rul  e ou supermodel Sosa
Halle première fois sahasrara construit et
votez démocrate est-ce dans la stratégie, alors
continuez tout d'abord en sautant simplement
les quatre premiers états et en disant que je
vais intervenir plus tard n'est pas quelque chose
qui n'a jamais été fait avec succès
Bloomberg mais a les ressources  pour
attirer l'attention de la publicité pour
rester en jeu, il est facile de dire battre Trump
Donald Bloomberg una Familia de dólar de
pasión clé de publicité zone d'exclusion aérienne comme Mike
Bloomberg comme l'avocatier au sommet d'une
carte Sony l'abus élargira
la couverture des soins de santé - Satsuki  hub Sony
massage aux pilules génériques sur Sherlock
tout démocrate dans la course dont la société
Sudha forme et à travers ces
groupes de discussion, ils nous ont en quelque sorte dit quels étaient
les principaux problèmes importants que les
Caroliniens du Nord soutenaient chacun avec d'excellents
soins de santé et un congé payé l'un était la
santé  les soins en second lieu étaient l'environnement, le
troisième était le contrôle des armes à feu et le quatrième était le
CBN éducatif, c'est votre nouveau pourrait
ressembler à Luke, vous ne vous souvenez pas de l'avoir fait  La
violence armée spéciale, je veux dire ici à
Charlotte, cela a été un problème pour nous, donc
et il s'attaque déjà à la NRA
avant que ce ne soit le type de leader, je pense que les
gens sont une des raisons pour lesquelles les gens sont enthousiasmés
par sa campagne.
dupliquer
occasionnel ne même pas PB ville sur l'
opération de Philly nettoyer et protéger les
terres publiques de l'Oklahoma ne sera-t-il pas par exemple
sûr de ne pas regarder la protection de
votre gentil homme pourrait lâchement il peut l'
obtenir s'il l'obtient c'est al  tusi la
publicité la personne que la personne contacte
est beaucoup plus efficace pour amener les
gens à voter la
publicité traditionnelle n'est pas très bonne pour ça
Côté personnel Schusterman Bloomberg LP
pour réserver une limousine Lourdes Assam presse
Kamala des est une station de performance lordy
debug donc quand le  travail d'un petit fou
sous la situation inquiet
gêné par la rencontre ne montrez pas
la fin courte d'une présidence sur la
vidéo de Rosetta Felicity sélectionnez un évent
la victime - pas d'exemple de Cooper
trouver le silicium le Bloomberg Tramp le mélanome
mais pour une population pourquoi le démocrate par
la vista à cette analogie chef Deborah
table d'arbres cul formidable J'envisage
toujours quelques candidats mais
je pense que je penche vers la droite parce que
Je crois qu'il doit y avoir une stratégie
dans cette campagne politique plus facile
maintenant c'était Bloomberg asahi est une stratégie
donc le président aurait
[Applaudissements]